podcast man we got the homie jay mills
yeah yeah yeah yeah what's up man
welcome sir what up what up
um all right man you got a new project
that's officially out
we're paying the walls by the time this
is out it'll be out
yeah we're painting the walls wood
painted walls wood panel
with panel walls yeah so what's that
what's that like in the car
you get the wood panel you know what it
is it's like uh i grew up in new york
city in washington heights
so a lot of those apartments was the
architecture was real
old school it might have like i know the
kind of walls you're talking about yeah
it might have like
five six rooms but when you first come
in it's a long
hallway but it'll be a room on this side
then a room here
then a kitchen then the room here then
so my grandmother had one of those
apartments right
and when i was born i was living in my
grandma's crib
she from down south right had 11 kids so
the house was very
busy but i'm a virgo
so my memory bank is incredible like i
can remember things
that i probably shouldn't remember and i
didn't even try to remember right right
right right but the wood pin
wall [ __ ] is stuck out you know what i'm
saying like rest in peace to my
grandmom's they have those in trailers
too
yeah they got him in trouble my uncle's
trailer it's like wood but it's not real
wood yeah
is that what used to be on side of like
the station wagons too yeah i think so
you know griswold ride mm-hmm wildly
world vibes old school
yeah it sounded like that like three's
think like three's company like
you know you got the little i know
panels all and my grandmom's crib was
all like that so when i went to do this
project
kind of like what we were talking about
the other day i
i've come from an era of the radio
record
the street single right to this record
you know what i'm saying so this was the
first time i was like man [ __ ] all that
let me just record
let me record a story you know i got so
many stories so many memories let me
just record some [ __ ]
that i could paint a picture from track
one to track whatever's gonna be the
last one no radio records it ain't no
party [ __ ] no strip club [ __ ]
it ain't really too much with a bounce
but if you listen to it from beginning
to end
it's a good story